oh yeah there's spiciness happening over
there oh yeah we dropped the turd
your belly oh fight face bite i'll bite
your face back i'm taking you i'm
stealing you wow
hey doing channing tatum here uh gonna
answer some questions for buzzfeed while
playing with uh puppies apparently bring
the prey the puppies
hi
what's up hey you crazy thing hey you
crazy thing how are you crazy today oh i
know
it's terrible actually uh it was not fun
at all i definitely won't be in out the
next movie uh that i if i ever direct
again i definitely won't be in it
and definitely not going to do it with a
dog
because you can see that there they they
really help you focus
favorite memory was when one of them bit
reed my co-director bit read right in
the stomach
oh make out section
i might be pregnant after this
hi she's like i made out with him
already i want to make out with
everybody else
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh wrestlemania the hardest thing about
directing a dog is that they're a dog
and they don't care about your movie
they just care about treats but other
than that
it's great they're really awesome they
make you be really present
look i get to like see read every day
and i get to like create all kinds of
things we we produce stuff we write
together we we do all kind of things and
magic like live stuff but kevin nash is
someone i don't get to see every day and
oh my god
i got a new candidate in here i'm taking
you i'm stealing you what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
nash is one of the most hilarious people
that have most hilarious humans i've
ever met in my life she's hit my throat
you're a mean one
you never know what's going to come out
of his mouth and to get to like play
a in a scene with him is it's kind of
crazy because like he's lived such a
life that
everybody always wants him to play this
like big scary guy because he's like six
nine he's massive he's actually really
incredibly funny and insanely smart and
to get to play a scene that he doesn't
have to be this like intimidating dude
it was really it was fun
i wrote a story about my daughter um
ultimately kind of going to school for
the very first time and becoming like
self-conscious about you know how
brightly she dressed and you know i
watched my daughter have like this
moment of like i don't want kids to make
fun of me for like what i'm wearing like
she usually she loves like wearing like
very funny funny clothes and things and
i just wrote like a little a little
story about it and it kind of turned
into something a little bigger than what
i even imagined it would be yeah it was
really great and my daughter loves it
like she really you know we we all the
jokes and the inside jokes that we have
naturally made it into the actual story
oh man you guys love this ear what's in
there what are you trying to get out
oh yeah we dropped the turd drop the
deuce we got a lighter puppy over here
the white one could win a foot race
i'm rehearsing for magic mike three and
out we're
we're
dancing for like
in a garage in the valley doing doing
very despicable things for about two
three hours a day and then i go home and
do cardio and then i work out late at
night
i would say turbo from uh from breaking
one not a musician
i don't know weird al yankovic
it's gonna be a completely categorically
different movie we're gonna essentially
make the the super bowl of stripper
movies we went and made these live shows
which were kind of my answer to like
making a third movie and because the
first two movies were these movies about
guys essentially
and body slam
oh yeah give me a growl oh you're mad
about it
your belly the first two movies were
basically
movies about guys but kind of made for
women in a way and i didn't really want
to make it oh yeah there's spiciness
happening over there i kind of was just
like we i don't want to make us i don't
want to make a third movie unless
there's going to be a really strong if
not
if not more central character than mike
so we have a very very strong and
central character that's a female in
this movie thanks buzzfeed appreciate it
she appreciates it as well go see the
movie dog february 18.
and please go to wags and walks rescue
these puppies will be there hopefully if
they're not already adopted hopefully
they will be adopted imminently because
they are insanely cute that one's out
that's going to live his own life this
one
loves to nibble how's that taste they
love kisses wags and walks guys wags and
walks rescue go
boom
my dog would eat you
[Music]